we're continuing our conversation today
with James Whitman who's the Ford
Foundation professor of comparative and
foreign law at Yale Law School also
author of the book
Hitler's American model which I have
here and have read so let's let's
continue our conversation from yesterday
and go in a slightly different direction
it's become in popular culture very very
common that people like to compare or
equate different people to Adolf Hitler
different actions to the Nazis in most
cases those comparisons are not
particularly accurate or apt I do want
to open the conversation with you about
what similarities there are today in
terms of rhetoric under the current
administration and and in the election
leading up to the current administration
to some of what was observed in
pre-world War two Germany and I'm really
gonna try to focus the conversation on
that and to differentiate this from a
Trump is like Hitler type of thing that
that is unfortunately a sort of sort of
out there if you're interested in
reading articles like that how can we
sort of start a conversation into this
and into exploring this in your set in
your mind well you're absolutely right
Trump is Hitler is not a very useful
claim and the idea that we're seeing
anything quite like Nazism in the United
States is really pretty thoroughly
misguided among other things we're not
seeing paramilitary killing people in
the streets the Nazi movement was
considerably to put it mildly more
ferocious than anything we've seen in
the United States what is true is that
in the early 1930s the Nazi Party
advocated something that bears an
obvious resemblance to and was partly
modeled on inspired by American
traditions of white supremacy that
involved four Nazis in the early 1930s
in particular large-scale reform of
immigration law efforts to drive the
outsiders out of Germany in order to
guarantee as the Nazi Party program put
it that the resources of Germany would
be devoted to the uses of Germans alone
and not to others that sort of rhetoric
is the sort of rhetoric we're hearing
again from from the out right it's
something that has a very very long
history in the United States
and there's no doubt that there's a
resemblance there no doubt that there's
a resemblance there whatsoever and it's
not surprising that the Nazis should
have drawn on the American example in in
working through their own racist program
in Germany in those respects and so
there's something to be said about that
I don't think that's the full extent of
the resemblance though there are
unexpected parallels to that deserve
even more discussion in my view and they
have to do with American legal culture
what the Nazis admired about America was
not just American racism and it has to
be said the United States was hardly the
only racist country on the globe in the
early 1930s or in the 20th century more
broadly what the Nazis admired most was
the extraordinary innovativeness and
creativity of American lawyers their
ability to discard all the conventions
of the law to forget all the sorts of
principles of lawmaking that had been
regarded as fundamental to civilization
for centuries in the name of creating a
new racist order now there are two there
are American tendencies that are still
at work in our country when we see Steve
Mann and if I may mention and once again
expressing his eagerness to deconstruct
the administrative state we're seeing a
spirit of rejection of convention
rejection of tradition that was also
there in the 1930s and the Nazis found
quite exciting particularly radical
Nazis who were great admirers of the
American approach there's um some other
similarities I'd love to run by you I
mean I see that the the revival of the
sort of mass rally under the campaign of
Donald Trump and the rallies that are
sort of worth it for the entertainment
value alone strikes me as similar to the
Hitler rallies of the early 30s the in
politics there's often been demonization
of opponents that's nothing new but the
sort of particular flavor of
demonization of opponents that we've
seen by Trump which is riddled with
these sort of egocentric delusions
that's another way in which sort of the
rhetoric of the Trump camp
struck me as similar to pre-world War
two Germany what do you think about that
I think that's true although I'm the
parallel to which I would coin is less
Hitler than Mussolini
mm-hmm and one often thinks in fact
Trump allows his chin to jut out in a
mussolini Escalade I don't know whether
it's done consciously
but in that respect the what you're
describing looks more a little more to
me like Italian fascism which for all
its evil was not quite as horrific as
German Nazism then it does like the like
German Nazism but there's no doubt that
it's there and once again it's it's
worth emphasizing without laying too
much weight on it that that sort of
thing was there in the in the early
1930s in the United States - there was a
lot of pageantry in the early New Deal
and while there was no Twitter there
were fireside chats and radio addresses
some of the saying now this is not by
any means to datura frankly Roseau there
was a great president with with a brush
of Nazism at all but to say that there
are populist forms of government that
have been appealing in the United States
for a very very long time and it can
easily be turned to the wrong uses well
that's sort of the difference between a
progressive populism versus what's
described at least in in waves of rancor
by Hillard and Keith who write about
this as a regressive populism in other
words a populist message that scapegoats
typically the other as bearing the
responsibility for the status quo which
of course is presented as being
absolutely terrible and the sort of
charismatic in a way authoritarian esque
politician presents his candidacy as the
fix right we will it with Hitler's case
it was we're gonna retrieve we're gonna
get back German pride we're going to get
revenge on those who have hurt the
country we are going to fix the economy
unemployment with Trump it's you know
build the wall get these 11 million
undocumented immigrants out a moratorium
on Muslim immigration the I alone can
bring you a panacea I think is an
interesting
I think you're making an awfully good
case there there's a lot to what you say
of course there's a question that's the
reverse of the question that I asked in
my book whether all of what we see in
the call it the the outright aspects of
Trump or in any way modelled on memories
of what went on in Europe in the middle
of the 20th century that I don't know
hmm
I can't speak that question but the
resemblances I think you're right are
there here's the last thing I want to
touch on from a legal perspective I have
many conversations with people who are
understandably worried about the
authoritarian tendencies at mostly so
far in rhetoric but also in terms of
legislative ideas from the current
administration here in the US and I know
many people who say whatever redder
rhetorical similarities we may find
between Trump and whoever else we want
to point to in history the legal
infrastructure of the United States when
it comes to the rights afforded by the
Bill of Rights when it comes to freedom
of the press etc that will prevent a
real move in the authoritarian direction
of the law that couldn't happen because
no matter what it is that the
administration ban and Trump whoever
would want to do our legal system would
not allow that to happen
is that reasonable to you or is that
something people should not immediately
write off in that way I don't know how
much our legal system would stand in the
way I think there is a culture of
democracy that's likely to stand in the
way mmm
that is you know things could have
turned quite bad in the 1930s and they
didn't I don't think in the end that's
because the legal system stood up all
that effectively to the dangers it's
because the traditions of democracy were
so strong in the United States they
couldn't be broken in that sense I like
many law professors that I'm a bit of a
skeptic about the importance of law and
legal institutions I think the general
culture matters matters more the other
thing I would say just quoting the
wonderful line have been witness is that
while we see many things that seem quite
disturbing in the Trump administration
in large measure what we're seeing is
malevolence tempered by incompetence as
he said you know Hitler and
Eleni were much much much more effective
at assuming the reins of government than
the people in the White House now seem
to be in the United States and that's
heartening too
it's heartening but also if we're just
counting on incompetence to prevent bad
things from happening that's also not
exactly the the the most promising
promising perspective is it I didn't
mean it as a cheery reading of what's
coming Wow okay well we've been speaking
with James Whitman the book is Hitler's
American model the United States and the
making of Nazi race law very very
interesting discussion thanks so much
for joining me in talking about it thank
you a great pleasure